You see it on the masks. They say the surgeon general United States said,
do not buy masks there. They will harm people. If you buy the masks,
don't buy masks. Then later you have to buy the masks.
The disease will be spread on surfaces. The disease won't be spread on surfaces.
The disease will be spread by asymptomatic people.
The disease won't be spread by asymptomatic people, right?
The list goes on and on. And actually it gets to a distinction.
You talk about a lot.
The distinction between say Progressive's are leftists and classical liberals,
right? Well,
what the progressive project has been telling us for a hundred years now is
forget about politics.
Forget about debate and persuading your fellow citizens and engaging in
questions and making ethical choices.
Just pick some experts in lab coats.
They are going to find the indisputable answer.
They're going to tell you all how to live your lives.
And even if they contradict themselves the next day,
we just have to do what they say.
And I think what we're beginning to learn now is no,
we actually have a right to speak about this too.
We're not just going to blindly.
[Inaudible].
This is the Rubin report. And I'm Dave Rubin.
Don't forget to subscribe to that YouTube channel.
We've got over there and click the notification bell.
And joining me today is the host of the Michael Knowles show on the daily wire
and a best-selling author, Michael Knowles. Welcome to the Rubin report. Dave,
thank you for having me. How is we not done this before?
Something doesn't seem right here.
Like the universe is sort of lining up right now, but how did this not a lie?
I liked that it took a pandemic for us to really do it. I know.
Are we allowed to shake hands? I, you want to shake hands?
I'm going to shake your hand on camera because you know this,
I think with the rest of the world, doesn't know this on super Tuesday,
which was what was that? February was that March it's like March 2nd.
It was a while ago. That was like right at the beginning of Corona. Yeah,
super Tuesday. I'm with you guys at the daily wire,
just as Corona is bubbling up.
You are the last hand that I shook as I was walking out of there.
I shake Shapiro's hand. I shake Klaban's hand whoever else in the crew.
And then I walk out of there. You're the last one that I shake.
And then we went into lockdown the next day. So short of David,
I have not touched another, the last one,
according to the latest medical science, if you ever get Corona, it's my fault.
I think. Well, the best part,
the best part of that is that then it turned out that I guess a few days before
you were at, uh, where were you using?
SeaPak you were at SeaPak and it turned out somebody at SeaPak shook somebody's
hand and I'm like, man,
I'm going to get Corona virus now because NOLs was at sea Pat. It's right.
Shook my hand. But yet we're both here and we're both healthy. We both survived.
It's so funny because right after that,
the reason that became a big story at SeaPak is I was there with Senator Cruz
and we were doing this, this live show we're in the green room. And there were,
there were a lot of important people in the administration.
There was like Kellyanne Conway. It was Ronald McDaniel was the head of the GOP,
all in this very small room.
And one guy tested positive for Corona virus.
So all of a sudden you have all these people locking down quarantining for weeks
and weeks.
And I thought I've just re ruined the Rubin report because I'm the last guy that
he touched.
Not only the Rubin report,
if any of this had had the veracity that they told us it was going to have,
right? You would have taken out the daily wire.
You would have taken out half of Los Angeles. And yet we're all here.
Well, because we found the cure, you know, we found the cure to coronavirus,
which it turns out is nationwide race, riots, racism.
I thought it might be hydroxy Clark. When I thought it could be,
they maybe get a vaccine. Nope. Turns out a race riots.
That's the cure to the virus.
Oh, you're being slightly sarcastic there. You know,
we've had public officials that have said that, that have literally said,
if we get the second wave of Krone,
it will not be because of the disease itself. It will be because of racism.
This is what one of the health commissioners of New York city said.
Not, not just one. There was this,
this letter that came out a couple of weeks ago. I think it was about 1200,
over 1200 public health officials who said, there are,
there are riots and they didn't say right. They said,
there are protests going on right now, peaceful, very peaceful,
social justice protests against racism.
Those should be encouraged from a public health perspective.
But the protests that went on a few weeks before against the lockdowns,
those must be discouraged because they are mostly white. And I, frankly,
I don't even know if that's true. Yeah. And this was the kicker. They said,
from our perspective as scientists, we know that white supremacy,
which is totally a real thing.
White supremacy is a public health threat that exacerbates Corona
virus. This was a shock to me. I didn't,
we don't know that much about the virus, but we do know that.
How do you feel being a pundit in the stupidest stuff?
I've been thinking a lot about this.
I think this is the best time to be a pundit to be in politics
because we've been living in this fiction for an actually a number of years now,
which is that there is science, right?
And science with a capital S trademark over the E is you can't argue with
science. Science tells you what to do.
We bow down and pay obese sins to the God of science.
And what we're finding out is a lot of this science is not so certain.
It's actually a little bit more political than all that. I mean,
obviously in coronavirus, they've basically admitted it.
You're telling me that the who the world health organization could potentially
occasionally possibly be wrong about things.
I would never want to contradict the Chinese communist party. We are on YouTube.
Yes. I know exactly. But this is the.
But he, but that sort of thing where it's like, I mean,
because we're so in the same world here,
I mean that we have to believe these people. The second they say something,
even though two weeks later, they say the complete reverse right.
Related to masks or whatever it is.
And then we are doing this on YouTube and I'm sure they're going to suppress the
views on this.
But the simple truth is YouTube said you can't contradict the who,
which contradicts itself all the time. Right?
You see it on the masks. They say the surgeon general United States said,
do not buy masks there. They will harm people. If you buy the masks,
don't buy masks. Then later you have to buy the masks.
The disease will be spread on surfaces. The disease won't be spread on surfaces.
The disease will be spread by asymptomatic people.
The disease won't be spread by asymptomatic people, right?
The list goes on and on. And actually it gets to a distinction.
You talk about a lot,
the distinction between say Progressive's or leftists and classical liberals,
right?
W what the progressive project has been telling us for a hundred years now
is forget about politics.
Forget about debate and persuading your fellow citizens and engaging in
questions and making ethical choices.
Just pick some experts in lab coats.
They are going to find the indisputable answer.
They're going to tell you all how to live your lives.
And even if they contradict themselves the next day,
we just have to do what they say.
And I think what we're beginning to learn now is no,
we actually have a right to speak about this too.
We're not just going to blind you.
What do you think the psychological underpinning of that is with Progressive's
because I, I get it. I've thought a lot about this. I wrote about this. Like,
what do you think it is about the progressive mind that they pretend they're
anti-authoritarian all the time. And yet they love authoritarian voices.
Actually, all their policies are authoritarian all the,
every time there's a study that that proves what they want.
Then that's the right study.
And everybody else's is the racist study or something like that.
But do you think there is like a psychological reason to it? I do.
I think it actually it's, it's a philosophical and a psychological reason,
and it goes back to Carl Marx and it actually goes back to this idea of science.
So if you go all the way back to the word, science,
science just refers to knowledge,
it comes from the Latin word for knowing things, right. And yet,
now the word science has been minimized. It's been truncated into this,
a little tiny aspect of material inquiry and empirical inquiry. Right?
So everything else that we have,
we have to say about knowledge is kicked out of that.
And what Mark said was he discovered a science of history,
and this is what progressive say, it's right there in the word,
progressive is we're progressing towards something it's inevitable.
Barack Obama used to always quote Martin Luther King Jr.
Who would always say the arc of the moral universe is long,
but it bends toward justice, basically,
meaning we're inevitably hurdling toward this progressive utopia. And you,
you can stand in the way for a little bit,
but you're not really going to stop it. And so.
And don't forget, history will judge.
You and you'll be on the wrong side of history. Right?
All of this language basically turns politics into a science.
And the reason it does that is so that you can't disagree with it.
And that's been, the science is always, always right.
You can never disagree with it.
And what we're learning now is that was just an excuse.
That was a facade to cover up their political choices.
And so I think the authoritarian impulse there comes because they
know that we're going to paradise. They see the utopia right ahead of,
and so if you stand in the way of utopia, you can only be one of two things,
really evil or extremely stupid. And either way,
we shouldn't be listening to you.
And the funny thing about this is they think the word utopia means the best
place, but it doesn't mean that the word actually means no place.
It doesn't exist. And I think a lot of people are.
Well, there's a semi autonomous zone in Seattle, I think, is,
is there utopia or whatever the hell is going on there?
I don't mind me asking your lady never tells me, okay. You're,
you're young fella out there in the political world.
And I always find it interesting when, when I meet younger conservative.
So especially now at college, when I meet younger conservatives,
because I think you, at least,
although I do think this is changing now for at least a decade,
really more than a decade,
probably a couple of decades to be a young conservative was like, you're,
you're just sort of this dorky, stuffy, whatever. You're a nerd. You, you,
you know, you care about numbers. You don't know anything about culture.
You're not funny.
You don't like comedy or any of these things where you always a
conservative and how do you see that sort of changing right now?
Because I really see it changing.
I see it. I mean, I think we're,
we're in the midst of it changing pretty radically.
I basically came out of the womb.
Smoking cigars, parted hair.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlist, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.